hey everybody welcome to a very final
look into what this map looks like in
which I want to show off a bunch of
stuff that I couldn't really show off in
the cinematic video for a couple of
reasons for one this city needs mods to
open it that aren't actually supported
anymore like traffic plus plus and find
Road Heights and because of that it's
really hard to get it to work and it's
really unstable and traffic for instance
is really broken as well and for that
reason I want to get rid of this city
get rid of all the mods that I needed to
get to get it to work and that I don't
have anymore and never open this city
ever again and for that same reason I'm
also not going to actually make a
download link to the city so really the
videos of it are the only real thing
that will stay of it at in that sense I
guess this is one last look into knowing
what it looked like before it just more
or less died another reason is that I
recorded a episode 23 of their let's
play series in which I made this city
but I accidentally removed the footage
of that and there were a couple of
things that I still wanted to go over
that I did in that video which were
actually some requested things most
importantly how I did my public
transport in the city some things that
you don't really see on the surface
level of what the city looks like so
that's what I basically want to go over
in this video and if you zoom out you
can really see how not that large
actually this city is this is like the
481 tile map and I'm not really sure how
many tiles the city exactly fills but it
is quite a few like it's about a little
bit more than a quarter of the entire
map reason that I didn't fill the rest
is just because time constraints and I
want to move on to something else but
this is basically what it looks like if
you zoom out I'll give a bit of a tour
of the city as well but first I do want
to get into the public transport a bit
because that's the most requested thing
so the way that looks is I've only got
trains and buses for the very important
reason that this seems like a medium
sized city and another --lens which
don't ever have a subway system the only
like city with a four grown subway
system which is actually underground and
has multiple lines is Rotterdam which is
this one out of the many cities and as
for a tram network I didn't want to get
trams because it just seemed like a
slightly too small city to get trams
into and it also isn't the most handy
city to get trams into since they're
there's so much water and so many parks
that make the road layout it's not
really to fit for that however I did
want to have quite a few train lines and
the road layouts from the first episodes
onward was more or less built to get the
shuttle bus um well bus services I
suppose I could call it and that's the
most important thing of the public
transport in this city and for that
reason I also want to show it off a
little bit I've got quite a few lines
over here this UI is very messy though
and the way that it basically works is
in the city itself all of these lines
are shuttle lines that aren't any loop
lines I haven't really found any loop
lines in the Netherlands and at least
ones that I use around the area of
Rotterdam don't have any loops
whatsoever so these are all just back
and forth lines but they do connect to
each other so within the big city itself
the most important line is this one
which connects the rest of the city to
the University because this part of the
city has a direct train connection to
the University so I didn't want to have
any direct bus line connection there
because that seemed quite redundant but
this part of the city doesn't have any
direct connection to the university so
having this line over here helps with
that but also it helps to connect all of
the different bus lines that I have in
here which you can see we've got the
orange one here which connects this part
of the city to the Central Station which
of course is a pretty important our
public transport hub in the city but it
also directly links to this big green
line which connects all of the parts of
the city to new unit to the University
so you can switch between these lines
say you live here and you want to get to
the University you could take a bus to
this green line here and take the Green
Line to the University things like that
same goes for the blue line over here
which goes to the northern part of the
city
you might notice that they do loop
around at the end of their tracks I
think a much better loop actually here
would be the orange line here which like
many of the bus lines here do they do
have a small loop at the end of it I
don't think too many bus lines have them
but I didn't want to give them a little
bit of extra coverage in the
neighborhoods like I think the most
important thing about having looping bus
lines is and is that in many cases they
don't actually end up being the most
efficient choice because if you have a
bus line actually loops you can only
take it into one direction so if you
want to go into the other direction in
many cases you're just easier off with
taking the car anyway but in this case
since it's such a small loop and it only
sort of makes the coverage bigger on the
area that I want to connect to the
Central Station seems like it's a pretty
efficient choice in this case and the
same goes for the Purple Line over here
as well which connects these parts of
the city to the Central Station the only
thing that I don't have which I suppose
I could have done and in hindsight I
probably should have done as well is
connect anything to the town center here
which doesn't have any bus line going
through it for one I figured I want to
have as little traffic through this
place as I can which is also why all of
the roads that connects this here are
more or less just one big maze and not
really that nice to go around because
otherwise this city center could become
a shortcut if you want to get from this
part of the city to this part which was
definitely not why I wanted to have
since people are going to have to use
like the transportation sort of most
important things if the road network
here around it and I'm going to keep as
much traffic out of the city centre as I
can but in hindsight a bus line maybe
should have been nice I just thought for
quite a while it's pretty much right
outside the Central Station so
especially for tourists if you come into
the Central Station to visit the centre
of the city you're only going to have to
really go over this quick bridge over
here and you're already in the centre
but um yeah maybe in hindsight I could
have just had one small bus line go
through the middle of this thing anyway
that's the basic bus connection
I do think it works out quite well to
have this one sort of important bus line
connecting the different parts of the
city and the three different bus lines
that connect that line to the main
transportation hub over here and now
obviously I also wanted to connect the
towns to it so we've got let's check it
out we've got this one here um [ __ ] I
need to get back into that UI right I'm
still not too used to that yet okay so
getting this back there is a line which
is the yellow line here which connects
the town of Larson to the town of Weston
um which might seem a bit strange as
well because they do have a direct train
connection which is in most cases going
to be at least a little bit more
efficient than that but what's good
about this bus line is that it actually
it does take a bit of like a shorter
route I could have also rerouted that to
go to the University even though the
university also has a train station here
but yeah anyway this one actually
connects to the stop that stops that
hour in between its so in these houses
over here and in the industrial section
over here and over here so it's a little
bit more efficient than the train if you
want to get through one of those areas
in the middle of these two places and
now similarly I have the Western um
after day line over here which connects
it to the town over here and what's
special about that line is that after
like over here it doesn't actually have
any train station and the only real
connection it has to the rest of the
world is this very small regional
highway over here so I do suppose this
bus line is quite important and also it
serves as the shuttle to the theme park
over here which didn't seem quite large
enough to have their own theme park
shuttles which many theme parks do have
I think for the time being I'll just let
it free load off of the regional bus
since no this is a somewhat small town
there's not gonna be that many people
that want to go from this small town to
the city over here and vice-versa so I
do think it's fine with the theme park
on that same line and last but not least
what importance we have the bus line
that connects these two towns there
isn't actually a road in the middle of
these like there's a very large stretch
of a canal over here which still
actually have a road bridge over it
there is the bicycle bridge over here
which make sure that these can these
towns are at least connected by bike but
if you're a person that drives a car or
is taking the bus you're gonna have to
take this very large hem winding
regional highway to actually get the
connection between the two and I reckon
it's a very often used line although it
still has 173 that's not too bad but
it's still it's pretty important to make
sure that these people all the way out
in the farmlands at least have some sort
of connection to the rest of the world
right so um yeah that's the bus system
now to actually give a tour of the city
itself which the cinematic video should
have already done pretty well but this I
guess is a bit more of a backstage look
into it and I can at least explain a bit
more what I was going for this is the
oldest part of the city gameplay-wise
it would also be a somewhat old parts of
the city city wise but one thing which I
would change if I were to go back into
the city is basically replace the houses
because the problem that I have with
this area is the first area that I built
and I was just really inexperienced when
I did so is that this area has a very
modern style layout it's very similar to
the layout of a mirror which was the
main inspiration for it but I used the
like the 50s
retro houses for it if you don't know um
basically there there are very specific
sort of time slots that you can think of
in Dutch urban planning and a very
common one is shortly after the Second
World War that was obviously a housing
shortage so many towns built all of
these like red roof row houses and very
straight road layouts but the problem
with this is that it's not really a 50s
Road layout it's a very 90s ish road
layout but with these houses that are
very 50s so um that's the one problem
but for all purposes we'll just consider
this a very newly built sort of parts of
the city since many of the parts of the
city are very newly built and a much
newer section which might actually be
the newest part of the city especially
over here where all of the trees are
still very small and still have to grow
please that's the idea behind
we've got this big sort of helix winding
v-necks ish housing development here and
especially this one I'm quite a big fan
of this one it's very small and it's
close to the center but these are really
some of the 90s and Xero is very newly
built housing developments with much
more experimental Road layouts and
different colors and textures on the
houses just much more playful and
interesting to look at as well
especially from the air kind of layouts
they're very similar to what you would
see in many of the Phoenix neighborhoods
in the Netherlands which all things
considered are more or less suburban
sort of areas for the Netherlands what's
also quite interesting about these is
many of them do have this sort of shared
space concept of using the roads both as
play areas as areas for cars and areas
for cyclists which is why many of these
Road layouts do seem very inefficient
they don't actually use any grids which
is more or less used to keep all of the
like local or all of the regional
traffic off of the very local roads you
will have as little traffic as you can
on these roads over here like the only
car traffic that you want is traffic
that actually goes to the destination
over here and all of these roads that
sort of go through it that actually do
connects in an efficient manner are
where you want to go from one side of
the city to the other
this is basically where the real
transportation is going on and all
things considered these are going to be
very quiet quiet and boring roads really
now moving on we've got the little CBD
of the city it's a small city and it has
a 120 meter tall millennium tower over
here at least like I think it's that's
all it's one of my favorite buildings in
the Netherlands though and even though
it seems like a very large building for
a city this size I just wanted to get it
into the city because it's that
beautiful of a building a Central
Station over here then there's the very
old core of the city here which is the
only really old parts of the main city
of Aston um I suppose um a bit of
cauliflower over here which didn't
really turn out as well as the
cauliflower in some of the other towns
and a bit of like newer house
developments on this side as well very
heavily inspired by Connie Solana in
Baden death and in the middle we've got
sort of a triangle between many very
large roads and the railroad as well so
this is the most accessible part of the
city or it is why I wanted to have the
football stadium over here a cinema and
the ski resorts while the indoor ski
resort for all you touch is out there
who don't actually have any mountains or
snow in the winter and the University
campus which is quite large heavily
inspired by many of the more great liked
and Open University campuses in the
Netherlands and that's just about the
big city small industrial complex over
here the original planning was to add a
harbour over here but I didn't really
end up having enough time to get into
that so this is just farm fields now and
moving on we've got my favorite town in
the entire map just because of how
realistic I think this one turned out
there's all always some things that you
can improve on and with everything you
build you off easily pick up on stuff
that you can do better next time
but this in the end really turn out to
be my favorite one and it's not too much
that I don't like about this thing I
guess it's maybe just a little bit too
contained by the Ring Road like nothing
really comes out of the Ring Road but
that's also part of the way that this
town works basically the idea is we've
got a very old core with a bit more of a
messy very old rote layout that isn't
really planned then we've got the 50s
post-world War two
retro houses over here we've got some
later cauliflower developments which
unlike some of the 70s though these look
more like 80s housing developments with
like more confusing roads but already
quite wide set up and with different
kinds of houses and many different
playgrounds all of between these houses
and we've sort of got like one very
modern city centre almost or a town
centre I should call it with some very
small supermarkets and the high school
of the town in there and that sort of
juxtapose is the very old city centre
which is not really where many of the
shops are located like functionally the
is more or less the town center and on
the top of the railroad which kind of
cuts through the town itself I've got a
few more houses some of these post-world
war ii houses over here and a bit more
new development over here with what I
think actually no this might be the high
school yeah I think for at least this is
functionally a high school but I would
say this should probably be a primary
school and this would be the high school
with a small hospital over here as well
and pretty much the mandatory sports
fields which you see many touchdowns
over there and that's the town of Lawson
my favorite in the entire our place just
because how its laid out and definitely
at this point I picked up much more
about how to lay out small towns like
this it's quite heavily inspired by
towns like Devon and here Youngstown
which are these really small rural towns
where nothing really happens but they do
have these interesting layouts now the
final city is the city of osterlich here
which means behind the dike and we've
got the small town of or like here which
means in front of the dike I still
regret those names probably shouldn't
have done it
but um these which is my sort of
work-in-progress
project names and I decided to keep them
and this city is quite similar to Lawson
it has that sort of old center but the
old center still has a couple of
shopping streets here and connected to
that is a sort of more modern shopping
area with the big parking lots here and
that's more or less the old core of the
town then we've got all of the
post-world War two retro houses over
here bit of random development around it
bit of cauliflower here like this is
really a town that sort of grows very
slowly and organically over time and a
bit more like 80s ish houses I suppose
over here and like the newest or the
most modern addition to the town just
very straight new row houses which is
right here and it doesn't have any
industry but the industry is located
just outside the town to the regional
Highway connection which is well that's
not very good and might actually be on
the roundabout here that's causing
problems I was hoping that I could get
an example of how traffic plus plus has
paid
Klee messed up the city but um now I see
that these bus stops over here are
actually one of the problems but um yeah
there's a lot of like cars that don't
nice pond or that stop at every
intersection as many issues with which
make like the traffic work a lot less
well than it should in this city which
is also one of the reasons why I want to
you know stop using the city and move on
to a clean one with better traffic
simulation I've got a small water
treatment facility which is the only one
that actually builds I was planning to
build one like right here somewhere for
the water treatment of the city itself
but that never really ended up happening
and last but not least we have the
awesome theme park over here which is
pretty much like the one thing that I
specialize in and the one thing that I
wanted to get right it's pretty small
theme park inspired mostly by slow
harden in the Netherlands has a very
small Dutch themed Main Street to it and
just those like large whining parts and
plazas with a bunch of attractions next
to it but it is quite a small theme park
it's nothing really large or really
worth mentioning I am not sure what
these cars are doing but it sure as hell
isn't what they're supposed to do guess
this would also be a pretty good example
for how screwed up my traffic is even if
I didn't really want to see that and
yeah it's really traffic jamming over
here as well it's very busy road here
but anyway that's the city that's
basically an overview of what the entire
thing looks like and what I didn't
really show specifically in the final
video oh wait there's one very small
town that I didn't show off in the final
video it's all which is the town of ky
came here one of the first towns which I
built which isn't really much just a
couple of houses Church and a windmill
it's a Dutch town after all and we've
also got the very small town of uh Paul
drafts over here which has a burnt down
house which is not very good hmm which
is right next to this highway rest area
one of the things which are broken over
here is that the parking spaces for some
reason have turned into very small
squares almost but um there's also two
broken
up in the city I don't quite want to go
over that the swimming-pool also
disappeared so I to very quickly replace
it with what is not a swimming pool at
all I have no idea what Silver City
actually is but it looks to be a store
of some sorts and this building used to
also be a different building that that
one was removed from the workshop I
believe in any case it just randomly
disappeared from the city anyway that's
really the end of this video I'm just
gonna have to end the city here I hope
to see you guys in the next series which
I'm not really sure when I'm gonna start
it and I'm also not really sure what
kind of city it's going to be it may be
an alpine city and it may be an economic
plan city I hope to go for a plan
economic city like Dubai or Doha
something like that the only reason
which would be why I am hesitant to try
it is that I've never seen anybody try
it before and I still kind of have to
figure out how I'm going to do it if I
figure out how to do it though and if it
turns into success I'm definitely going
to make something like to buy so that's
what I hope to do next time and we'll
see when that's going to happen anyway
thank you guys for sticking through this
entire series and this video as well and
yeah bye bye